hello everyone and welcome to a game you
guys requested as soon as it finished a
couple of minutes ago it's pragananda
versus magnus carlsen and it's around
five of this year's adjustable masters
preliminaries uh it's uh quite um uh
quite an enjoyable one so let's dive
straight into it and uh see if we can
understand what actually happened here
and why it did
so prague has the white pieces and he
opens with e4 it's going to be a
standard rue lopez nothing out of the
ordinary knight f3 knight to c6 and
bishop to b5 the real lopez is on the
board magnus goes for morphe's defense
a6 bishop to a for knight to f6 and now
d3 the anderson variation is now on the
board uh bishop to c5 and now c3 we have
b5 now chasing the bishop back bishop to
b3 and d6 now bishop to g5 pinning the
knight and h6 attacking the bishop
bishop h4 and bishop back to b6 with a4
by prague
uh going after the b5 pawn and now rook
to b8 as the
a file will open up the rook on a8 is
undefended uh and there are a couple of
games that reach this position but uh
the only move that was played here is
castles here prague goes for the
immediate eight captures on b5 and it is
now as of movie 11 that we have a
completely new game
uh so magnus accepts the pawn back or
recaptures so a captures on b5 and
knights the a3 probably goes after the
b5 pawn uh g5 challenging the bishop you
could also uh play b for right away but
here b4 is not that great of a move if
you if you play b4 then you get the
knight over to the c for square so first
magnus goes for g5 bishop to g3 and now
knight to a5 making room for his c pawn
to be pushed forward plus also you are
now controlling the c4 square with the
knight so now you are preparing this b
for idea uh with the plan of um
ruining uh white spawn structure so
bishop back to c2 also you are just
threatening to pick up the bishop here
so bishop back to c2 and now b4 so it's
a free pawn uh but uh your structure
will be will be ruined and here prague
goes c captures sun
on b4 uh this attacks the knight here uh
knight to c6 going back with the knight
and now bishop to a4 pinning the knight
and now you have to defend it of course
bishop to d7 magnus defense
knight to c4 and now uh knight captures
on b4 so instead of knight to c4 you
could also just capture if you don't
want to give the pawn back uh but prague
says he doesn't want to keep this double
b pawn
uh so knight captures on b4 bishop
captures on d7
knight captures on d7 and now both
players castle so castles castles and
now uh knight captures on b6 here prague
wants to win the d4 square and that's
impossible with the bishop controlling
it and he wants to get his pawn away
from d3 it's a backward spawn the knight
is attacking it so if you play d4 uh
everything should be fine so real
captures on b6 pawn to d4 going for this
breakthrough knight to c6 magnus now
attacks the pawn uh and rook the c1 uh
we have knight captures and e4 knight
captures e captures and queen captures
and here magnus just puts the knight to
the c5 and this is now an excellent
square magnus is also trying to trick
prague if prague goes b4 then knight to
b3 uh wins the game or rather should win
the game if black continues playing
perfect moves uh but uh you have to
prepare uh such a move so first rook c
to d1 mag prague moves the rook uh
knight to e6 now attacking the queen
queen back to c3 and now pawn to f pawn
to f6 with f4 uh prague wants to bust
open the position uh queen to e7
preparing to bring the other rook into
the game as well and now pawn to b4 now
ready to meet c5 would be capture c but
also taking away this knight from the uh
this is square from the knight so rogue
b to b8 um
just uh preparing to to set up a defense
on the on the c7 pawn f5 now challenging
the knight knight to d8 and rook to d
for now here prague will put his rooks
on the c file rook c4 rook to c1 and go
after the c7 pawn uh knight to f7 now
the knight can be shifted to e5 rook the
c4 threatening rook captures on c7 and
now rook to b7 uh helping out with the
defense this way uh rook to c1 adding uh
this uh
rook queen rogue battery uh uh to to go
after the c7 pawn and here you basically
have three types of players you have a
player that will just defend the pawn
you have a player that will play
actively with rook to b8 and go after
white's b for pawn and you have super
aggressive players that will just play
rook to a8 with the idea of going for
the attack regardless of what is
happening so these are the actually the
top moves in the position so magnus
decides to go for rook after b8 he wants
the semi-aggressive one but not another
defensive one
and now prague goes for h4
and this is already a very very uh
interesting uh
moment in the game because uh both
players are down on the clock but magnus
uh has um a few seconds on the clock
okay you do have increment but still
yeah probably trying to put pressure if
he wants he can always get a draw rook
captures and c7 is basically an instant
draw captures captures we're going to
trade everything captures captures
captures and after rook captures you get
this end game equal material bishop
against knight
so should be should be easily drawn but
pogba wants to continue pushing he plays
h4 wants to open up the position and
magnus plays just g captures on h4 now
this is uh seems a bit of a bit of an
anti-positional move uh just ruining
your pawn structure like this but we
know by uh you know uh consulting the
engine so many times that this is often
the the absolute strongest idea uh so
magnus does it without has hesitation
and also he just uh will get his to the
e5 without allowing bishop captures on
e5 so bishop captures on h4 and now
comes knight to e5 attacking the rook
and now uh prague finally goes for rook
captures on c7 so real captures on c7
rook captures we have a queen trait
captures captures rook captures on c7
and the rook captures on b4 so he tried
to delay it with that h4 idea maybe
trying to mix it up a little bit
but in the end he had to do it and now
we have rook to e7 so it's still not
it's it's still not clear if if you
can't get a draw here because uh
the f6 pawn is being attacked then maybe
these pawns become weak as well or maybe
magnus can do something let's say rook
captures an e4
but uh
after rook d7 we have d5 magnus says all
right this pawn is now weak you cannot
capture on d5 because the bishop on h4
hangs uh so king to f1 by prague and now
comes the d captures on e4 so now all of
a sudden magnus is up a pawn but bishop
captures on f6 prague wins the pawn back
and attacks the knight and here magnus
needs to play either knights to d3 or
knight to c4 and that is perfectly fine
however magnus with a few seconds on the
clock played knight to g4 and incredible
as it is and while i do believe you guys
can uh figure this one out without even
pausing the video just for the fun of it
as uh i mean it is a world champion
playing uh feel free to pause the video
and to win the game for prague while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting the idea
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is rook the g7 check
this is what the prague played and he
was in this position on move 41 that
magnus carlson resigned the game as he
just blundered a full knight once uh the
king moves you're gonna capture the
knight and there is absolutely no
counter play here uh so of course he had
to resign now you could say okay this is
just maybe a silly blunder uh it's not
it's not a real win as you guys usually
do right in the comments uh but i would
like to point out that uh prior could
have drawn this game uh much much
earlier if you wanted to if you just
traded off everything along the c file
they would you know repeat moves and it
would be a draw uh and uh for one and
for other uh prague really pushed magnus
he really uh pushed hard as magnus was
very low on time and in the end magnus
blundered a knight here so i i think
it's a legit victory and uh
and and a nice one at that so
congratulations to prague and not just
on defeating magnus but on defeating
magnus carlsen yet again so we'll see
what happens in their next encounter but
i'm i'm liking where this is going uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh magnus definitely didn't
blundering a knight like that but as as
you've seen it happens to everyone uh i
would like to thank david kimura adam
rosenberg uh francis robert kiefer and
mark manor for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the chessable
masters preliminaries until it ends so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
careful where you put your knights